So you started out in a different environment in public radio. Uh,
so how was that experience for you?
I guess I was relatively early in your career.
Yeah, I started, I, you know, right after college I had a, um,
crisis of identity and I didn't know what I was going to do.
So I started all first and, and I'm working as a financial advisor for, for,
for Morgan Stanley Dean Witter. And, um,
it was actually kind of during that miserable commute around the DC beltway,
I discovered public radio. And over a number of years,
I kind of set my sights on public radio because I realized that's really what I
wanted to be doing. I just loved the craft of it.
And I loved the way that they told stories.
I had never had a desire to go into TV. And, um,
I also didn't really do internships through college because I was, you know,
working full time and just a little bit lost in general.
So it wasn't until a while after college,
I discovered NPR and set my sights and I started at
NPR in 2002 and, um,
loved every day from, from the first minute.
So,
so you were attracted to NPR and I have to say when I was out there campaigning
around the country, NPR was like its own Oasis of news.
Like there were folks that listened to it. Uh,
the local NPR stations, uh,
seemed very free. They were very pure. You'd go in.
And they had listeners who really wanted a particular version of
both the news and the listening experience. Uh,
you were attracted to that and it sounds like you were there from 2002 to 2013
more or less. I mean, you were doing some other stuff, but it was all, uh,
public radio directed. Is that right? It's like 11 years or so.
Yes, that's correct. Yeah. Um, and yeah, I mean, I just,
this morning I was listening. I, you know, I listened to KQD frequently,
which is the San Francisco station. And, you know, it's, it's such a, you know,
pleasure because the, you know, the local, um, public affairs program forum,
they were, they covered, um, the local, um, uh,
drug overdose epidemic and how it's gotten worse through the pandemic.
And then they moved on to, um, the new COVID vaccines for another 30 minutes.
And it's this long in depth conversation and things that I didn't even know I
needed to know. But yeah, I mean, it's, it's,
it's just so much more and so such better information that you can get.
Uh, NPR is supported through, um, public funding. Um, the,
the NPR now has so many listeners and sponsors and advertisers that, uh, it's,
uh, largely self-sustaining and a lot of people have also donated to it. Um,
so it's like a combination. Um,
and then you wound up at MSNBC, which, uh, uh,
it seemed like your, uh,
experience was a bit different. Uh, how was the experience?
I kind of came into it with the attitude. I mean,
we knew that everything was kind of, you know, we knew that rating.
I knew that ratings, um, played a part and,
and our daily lives, um, I didn't understand the extent of it.
And I thought coming in,
I could bring my skills that I had in public radio.
And part of that is really trying to find new and
interesting and compelling stories and angles and voices,
and they would want to, you know, they would be,
they would welcome that because, uh,
in my mind I felt like one of my big criticisms of cable news coming into it
was the repetition. And when she said she felt like it was, you know,
you're watching the same five or six stories kind of all day throughout the day.
So, um,
I thought that that was an opportunity for me to come in and, you know,
make things better. Right. Um, so I,
I struggled with that for a few years. Um, I really, I, you know,
I tried different types of stories and kind of like strengthened my
pitches and, um, realize, okay, they might not listen to me the first time,
but I'll keep coming back and, you know,
trying to sell this other idea or strengthen my argument. Maybe they don't,
you know, maybe it's not intuitive, why something is a good idea.
And over time, I, you know, I, I got a little bit frustrated,
but, um, then started to get at the same times a little bit of seniority.
So I was more involved in the planning meetings, you know,
with the senior producer and the executive producer and,
or the senior producers. There's usually more than one.
And at that point I realized the extent that they really,
that the ratings really drove all of the decisions and it was,
it was it's down to, you know, it's the first thing out of their mouth.
As soon as you throw out an idea and they don't necessarily talk that way in the
wider editorial meetings with a full staff,
it really was in the S the smaller planning meetings. You know,
it's the first thing out of their mouth is like how things rated the night
before, how they thought something did. And those,
those ratings are broken down by quarter hours.
So they have a pretty good understanding of what did well and what didn't do
well. And so they will track the topics of course,
and they'll track the guests. You know, if, you know, if the guest does well,
or if aggress guest rates well or not,
they really rely on that, um,
for almost every decision. So, um, it that's,
it wasn't until the last few years when the reality,
um, became, you know, pretty stark to me. And then, you know, I,
wasn't going to be able to fight that fight. You know, there wasn't, you know,
these people are just doing their jobs and it's all out of their hands.
It's out of Lawrence's hands it's out of Phil Griffin's hand,
it's at a higher oil or pay level, um, where the, where the problems are,
you know, one of the things you said was that, look, these are good people.
Uh, you know, trying to do good work, but, uh,
they're put in a position where their job does not necessarily produce the kind
of journalism you'd want it to,
which is something I completely get and empathize with
is that if you put people in a position where their incentives are all steering
them one direction, you kind of expect them to end up, uh,
listening to those incentives. You know, it's like,
and if you don't listen to those incentives,
and let's say your ratings underperform, um, consistently,
then someone's going to make a change. And so, like,
that's the race you're always running. Um, like,
were there other people that ever expressed any misgiving,
maybe someone else from like a similar background as you.
Yes. Um, those conversations didn't happen very often,
but over the last year or two, when I was there,
there were times when I would have conversations in private with other
producers. And, um, certainly they, you know,
with a couple of people, um,
they w said, I think we're making things worse, you know? Um,
some seem to think that w yeah,
what we're doing here is probably benefiting Trump and will,
would help him get elected. Again, the person who said we are a cancer, that is,
that's one of those conversations. It was somebody in the building, um,
uh, and has been in the business a long time. So, um,
but it wasn't something that people talked about in the open, you know,
it wasn't until I went in and sat down, like kind of one-on-one with them. Um,
otherwise the, the con the, the notion that ratings drive everything, it's just,
it's really built into the process. And it's, it's of course, you know,
that's just, that's just what you do. And, you know,
most of those people came up through the commercial TV system somehow,
and I obviously have a public radio background,
and none of the editorial decisions I ever made before were based on how it
would rate or how big of an audience we thought we would have. I mean,
we always wanted a big audience. You know, you hope that, you know,
what you're doing is compelling enough to hold people's attention. Um,
but that's not what determines those decisions.
And so for me, see, you know, it was like, it,
it really raked against my nerves. Every time I heard them say something like,
you know,
that's not going to rate it when it's something that I knew would be a good
topic. Some of the decisions were made out of ideological reasons. Um,
but it also kind of drives the
division that, that we're seeing and the polarization in this, in the country.
So they might be pumping up, you know, um,
ideas that are exciting to some people, but then the world has never, you know,
they don't get excited about the, you know,
someone with a more nuanced or moderate take on things. And, um,
so that, that just kinda keeps driving everybody apart. And there's, you know,
you know, there's no sense that okay,
there is some benefit to compromise every now and then I just,
I know that that's not a popular idea right now because we've gotten so far away
from that. But, um, you know, the, the,
my sense is that it just,
when you stand back and look at the totality of, you know,
all the different ways that the financial incentives affect the content,
it's just driving us down the wrong path,
and it's only getting worse the way that I see it.
You do a couple of examples in your resignation letter,
which I recommend that everyone, uh, find and read,
because I just thought it was so brave and incisive and
true. Uh, so thank you for it. And I'm a huge admirer of yours.
You did something out of principle that the vast,
vast majority of people don't ever do. Uh,
and if enough people did what you did, we might actually have a chance.
And I don't mean just in media though, the media is a significant part of this,
but, uh, you know, in,
in many different environments where your financial incentives are to, uh,
just pretend it's okay. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.